[Music]
well it is thursday night this is our
last show of the week so i thought we
should check in with our own andy
richter see what stories he's working on
for next week andy
thank you conan
next week we'll visit a woman in
mississippi who thinks she saw jesus in
her pancake
and that hole in the wall in your office
should you put your hand in there
also this man's amazing story of how he
was not able to get you weaned aquarium
long beach that's like you know that's
the complete opposite direction but
there is a pickup game down there so
sugar mine yeah
and we'll tell you why grizzly bears are
switching from salmon to fish oil
supplements
and in st louis we'll visit a weird
homeless man who magically erects
buildings with his mind
wow
back to you conan thanks a lot andy very
nice job you look terrific
thanks so do you conan thanks pal all
right well folks we're gonna take a
quick
is it okay if i go now yeah i don't know
i don't know which camera i'm supposed
to be on
we'll take a break
look
wait i'll just come back yeah come back
[Applause]